وينضموا الينا هنا في الاستديو السفير
السعوديه لدى اليمن محمد الجابر سعته
مرحبا بك معي في النشره الرابعه من الرياض
حياك الله منور الله يسلمك اولا ما هي
تفاصيل هذه الاتفاقيه التي وقعت اليوم
لدعم برنامج الاصلاح بين صندوق النقد
العربي والحكومه اليمني بمبلغ مليار دولار
الحقيقه هذا
اللي حصل اليوم هو جزء من الدعم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الى الاشقاء في اليمن
استماره اليهود الكبيره اللي دعم الاقتصاد
والتنميه في اليمن وايضاته من قبل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من عده جهات من قبل
المركز الملك سلمان لغايه الاعمال
الانسانيه وايضا من قبل البرنامج السعودي
يتم الجانب التنميه والعماري وايضا من
جانب وزاره الماليه فيما يتعلق بدعم
الاقتصاد اليمن من خلال البنك المركزي
اليمني هذه الوديعه هي استمرار ودائع
سابقه مليار دولار في 2012
في 2018 وهي تركز على دعم الاقتصاد الدعم
الاستقرار الريال اليمني وكذلك ايضا همم
دعم الامن الغذائي من خلال توفير العمله
الصعبه للاشقاء في اليمن لدعم التجارب
ومردين لشراء المواد الغذائيه من الخارج
للداخل اليمني وقد حققت الحقيقه كثير من
نتائج في هذا الاتجاه واليوم الامر همم
الواضح هو مشاركه الصندوق العربي للنقد
بهدف اصلاح همم ما يتعلق بالجانب
الاقتصادي ورفع اداء الحكومه وبناء
القدرات وما تحتاج الحكومه اليمنيه في ظل
ما حصل لها من خلال الانقلاب منشات
الحوثيه عليها من 2014 حتى الان طيب ساعه
السفير يعني هذا البرنامج هو قادر على
تحقيق الكثير من من الاصلاحات فيما يخص
اولا اعاده بناء مؤسسات الدوله اليمنيه
تعزيز الحكم الشفافيه كما جاء في البيان
ومعالجه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
الصعبه التي يمر فيها اليمنيه بشكل اولا
انت عمرك البرنامج هو يساعد همم الحكومه
اليمنيه البنك المركزي وزاره الماليه وعده
قطاعات اخرى في حوكمه اعمالها
وخاصه انهم يعملون
العاصمه المؤقته عدن
والمؤسسات كانت هشه وضعيفه وهناك حاجه
لاعاده بنائها وتاهيلها بما يسمح لديها ل
همم ايضا لتوفير الخدمات اللازمه ومن
المهم جدا رفع هذه القدرات وبالتالي الجهه
القادره على العمل الدائم والمشترك وذات
الخبره صندوق العربي للنقد همم الذي يدعم
ليس فقط عبر هذه الوديعه بل هذه الوديعه
ما خلصنا اللغه العربيه ستمكن اليمن من
القدره على استحصال على قروض وايضا على
دعم من عده جهات
منظمه الدوليه اخرى
الاصلاح في هذا البرنامج
الشفافيه تكون شفافيه ايضا ما يتعلق بقدره
همم البنك المركزي اليمني على اداره
السياسه النقديه في اليمن وقدره وزاره
الماليه على اداره السياسه الماليه بشكل
شفاف واضح فيما يدعم الحقيقه هو استقرار
همم الاقتصاد اليمني استقرار الريال
اليمني وايضا توسيع الارادات وزيادتها
واتخاذ خطوات همم فعال وواضحه وشفافه ما
يتعلق همم المصروفات لدعم هذا العمل
الجميل في الامر ان اليمن عضو رئيسي في
صندوق العربي النقد وهي تعمل مثل هذا
الصندوق على هذه الاجراءات وبالتالي هي
تعمل مباشره مع صندوق العربي النقد ودورنا
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه هو تمويل
البنك المركزي اليمني من خلال صندوق
العربي للنقد الذي سيشل ان شاء الله من
خلال خبرات عربيه وحتى موجود يمنيه فيها
لدعم همم قدرات البنك المركزي اليمني سعد
السفير في
الشقه السياسي احنا لازم نحكي على الشقه
السياسي طالما انك همم موجود يعني معنا
اليوم اولا اريد ان اسمع تعليقاتك على
تصريحات السفير البريطاني اليوم قال بان
سلوك الحوثي المدمر للسلام وقال بانهم
يدينون الهجمات الحوثيه وصفها بالارهابيه
على الموانئ النفضيه اليمنيه ما في شركه
تماما مع ذكر همم
العالم لدى اليمن وكذلك همم جميع المنظمات
الدوليه تصف ما فعله همم الحوثيه باسلحه
من قصف موانئ ايرانيه هو همم ومراكش تصدير
ايرانيه النفط اليمني بعمليات ارهابيه
وجزء من العمل الارهابي تقوم بمليشيات
الحوثي همم في تصرف الحقيقه يضر بالشعب
اليمني في المقام الاول ويحطم ويدمر
مؤسسات الدوله وهو الحقيقه استمرار للشاعر
هذه الميليشيات في ضمير المؤسسات الدوله
وتدمير قدرات الشعب اليمني هذه المخدرات
الشعب اليمني وتقصف وايضا الصادرات هذه
النفط هي ايضا تودع في البنك المركزي
اليمني يقوم بصرف رواتب همم الاشقاء في
اليمن وبنظافه للدعوم التي نعمل على دعمها
فتصور الان في ظل ضعف الارادات الحكومه
اليمنيه التي تقوم بالصرف على شعبها
وتوفير الخدمات نحن المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في دوله الامارات والعديد من
الدول ومنظمات تقوم بدعم الدوله الامنيه
على سبيل المثال اليوم وقع على الملياردو
مع البنك المركز اليمني فهو بحاجه الى
عمله صعبه
لانه لا تتوفر لديه ايضا نقوم بها 200
مليون دولار طعمه دعم مشتقات النفطيه
لتشغيل المحطات الكهرباء ايضا للشعب
اليمني وتوفير الخدمات الشعبيه اليمني
وايضا 90 مليون دولار مستشفى العدن في عدن
90 لمده ثلاث سنوات لا تستطيع حكم
الالمانيه تشغيله بقدراتها الذاتيه ايضا
هناك همم دعم مختلف في جميع المشاريع
لدينا تقريبا 17 مشروع برنامج
كبير جدا اغلبها في عدن وفي المكلفه وفي
مارب وفي بالاضافه المشاريع السابقه اللي
بلغت حتى الان اجمالا المشاري نفذت او تحت
التنفيذ سيتمدها 2004 240 224 مشروع في
مختلف القطاعات السبع هو يوم البرنامج
السعودي وهو اعتقد في المركز الرابع من
اجل المنظمات الدائمه ايضا
حاليا
في المركز الرابع معنا
المنشد حديثا ثلاث سنوات توجيهات ولعت
الامر الله يحفظهم وهمم لدينا مشاريع لها
الحمد كبيره جدا بعضها سلم تقريبا 24
مدرسه سلم منها الكثير همم من اجمالي 32
مدرسه نفذ البرنامج منها 24 بشكل مباشر
وباقي المشاريع عن طريق منظمات يمنيه في
الداخل للحفاظ على المؤسسات اليمنيه وايضا
المشاريع مجال المياه والطرقات الطريق
العامره الان يتم المرحله الاولى منه هناك
مستشفى عدن مطار عدن مستشفى الغيضه همم
مستشفى مدينه الملك سلمان التعليميه
الطبيه وكذلك مطار المهره وايضا العديد من
المشاريع في الداخليه في الطرقات المجال
الكهرباء لدينا ايضا محطه كبيره جدا ستبنى
للتحويل الغاز همم بما يمكن من تشغيل محطه
الرئيسيه في عدم 250 ميجا باذن الله قريبا
عليها مع الحكومه ايضا ساعات السفير همم
تابعت لي تصريحات احمد عوض بن مبارك وفي
لقائه مع سفير الولايات المتحده مؤكده
فيها على اهميه ان يدعم المجتمع الدولي
لتصنيف الحوثيين الجماعه الارهابيه وانا
اريد ان انطلق من هنا اسال عن مساعي
الهدنه الامميه الى اين وصلت بعد ان تعثرت
خلال الفتره الماضيه ولم تجدد هذه لهدنه
الحقيقه ال- الهدنه همم المبعوث الامي الى
اليمن قدم مقترح يتضمن فتح مطار همم صنع
لخمس جهات جديده
والسماح بدخول مشتقات النفطيه وفق اليه
محدده لميناء الحديده
وفتح طرق تعز والعين من الطرق التي تساعد
الانسان اليمني في الحركه التجاريه
والحركه الانسانيه بالاضافه الى وقت اطلاق
نار في عموم اليمن وكذلك صرف الرواتب
للمدنيين تقليم الربع مليون انسان يمني
تقريبا سيحصل على رواتبهم في مناطق عليه
همم سلطه المليشه الحوثيه على ان تكون هذه
المرحله لمده سته شهور للاسف فرضتها
الحوثييه واصرت على
متطلبات جديده وشروط جديده همم المجتمع
الدولي يعمل الان همم في مسارها مسار دعم
هذه الهدنه ودعم السلام ونحن المملكه
العربيه السعوديه نعتبرها الخيار افضل
الخيار الاسلم والخيار ندعو له دائما
ونشجع من كافه الجوانب همم والخيار الاخر
وخيار الذي همم تختارهم للشيعه الحوثيه
ورفض الهدنه والعوده للحرب وهو خيار لا
يرغب فيه الجميع بما فيها الحكومه اليمنيه
وسمعتم جميعا تصريحات المبعوثه الامم في
مجلس الامن وتصريحات المجتمع الدولي ومن
الاتحاد الاوروبي اصدر بيان وصف المذيعه
الحوثيه بعملها في المكلا وكان بعمليات
ارهابيه نعتقد ان استمرار الحوثيين في
استهداف الموانئ المدنيه وكذلك منع تصدير
النفط او عمل الارهابي سيصل بها الى نقطه
العوده فيما يتعلق بتصنيفها منظمه ارهابيه
في مجلس الامن وفي كل الدول ذات العلاقه
الراغبه في السلام نرجو ان تتكلم المساعد
الدوليه والمساعي الاميه في اقناعات
الحوثيه همم بالعوده الى سواء
اخرى ايضا تحاول ان تساهم كذلك مع المبعوث
الاممي لدى اليمن في اعاده طرح تمديد
الهدره مره اخرس ما في شك زملائي سفراء
والمبعوثين وكذلك همم بعض الدول والمنظمات
تتواصل مع الحوثيين بشكل مباشر سواء في
صنعاء او لقاءات مباشره معهم في مسقط في
سعي منها لشرح الفائده المرجوه للشعب
اليمني من تمهيد الهدنه ودفع الاطراف
اليمنيه للتواصل السلام ما تقوم باهميه
الان هو تصعيد همم شديد جدا اثمن واشكر
الحقيقه قياده المجلس القياده مجلس
القياده الرئاسي وقيادته على تريوتها
وصبرها في اتخاذ الاجراءات من اجل منح
الفرصه للشعب اليمني للوصول للسلام والملح
الفرصه ايضا نشات الحوثيه ان تعود الى
رشدها وانت تدرك الابعاد همم الاساسيه
والدوليه الحاليه الراهنه همم للابتعاد عن
المسار الايراني والعوده الى المسار
العربي والمسار السلام في اليمن اشكرك
جزيلا الشكر على وجودك معي هنا في نشره
الرابعه ضميرينا في الاستديو ساعدت السفير
السعودي لدى اليمن محمد الجابر شكرا جزيلا
شكرا لك